am ersten februar 2021 findet eine
fitnesstrainerin eines ihrer work aus in
den straßen von libido der hauptstadt
von mähren und im hintergrund waren
vorbei rollen die panzer zu sehen
auf diese weise erfuhr die ganze welt
von mir als staatsstreich kurios nicht
wahr
die frage ist warum das erlebte er
überhaupt in myanmar geputscht hat warum
eigentlich sollten wir uns gerade um das
schicksal dieses fernen landes kümmern
hat die demokratie jetzt noch eine
zukunft und mehr macht in diesem video
werden wir es euch verraten
bleibt also dran denn wir haben auch
eine kleine überraschung für euch laut
werder fans politik
ich grüße alle träume waren sie so alt
politik mein name ist pablo ich bin eu
bürger der in rangun legt dem
wirtschaftlichen zentrum iran macht die
werde euch ein paar einblicke darin
vermitteln was wir hier dieser tage in
burma erleben ganz genau bei diesem
video hatten wir die hilfe einer person
die den staatsstreich in myanmar hautnah
miterlebt da die situation im moment
sehr gefährlich ist haben wir
beschlossen seinen nachnamen zu
verbergen um seine anonymität zu wahren
aber erst lasst uns mit dem video weiter
machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer einmal ist eines jener länder von
denen wir alle wissen dass es existiert
aber wahrscheinlich würden es nur wenige
von uns auf einer unbeschrifteten
landkarte auf anhieb finden eigentlich
ist das aber eine ganz logische
konsequenz denn jahrzehntelang war mehr
ein smartphone der welt völlig isoliert
bis 2003 war das südostasiatische land
eine art nordkorea allerdings ohne
kommunismus doch nur zwölf jahre später
2010 kürte die economist mehr zum land
des jahres in jedem jahr wurden im
januar die ersten freien wahlen
abgehalten
diese wahlen wurden von der dame die ihr
jetzt auf dem bildschirm sehen könnt
gewonnen
aus sushi keiner geringeren als einer
friedensnobelpreisträgerin man könnte
sagen dass diese frau die asiatische
version von nelson mandela
wusstet ihr zum beispiel dass youtube
ein song für sie geschrieben hat sie es
mit camping miramar als ich nach myanmar
kam um neue geschäftliche gelegenheiten
zu entdecken
bewegte sich in myanmar endlich auf die
demokratie zu es wurde so einer der
wenigen demokratien in südostasien
hinzu kommt dass es hier so viele
möglichkeiten gab nach jahrzehnten der
nationalen isolation
da ist unglaublich viel zu tun das land
verfügt über erdöl erdgas mobil werden
es produziert eine große menge an
nahrungsmitteln
außerdem ist es wunderschön hat also
viel tourismus potenziale
riesenpotenzial
doch unter dieser neuen demokratischen
regierung verfügte die armee von mir an
mache die sogenannte tam ag einen
völkermord an einer minderheit der
hingeht und zwar mit der unterstützung
der friedensnobelpreisträger
sie verteidigte das vorgehen der armee
sogar vor der internationalen
gemeinschaft ja und jetzt revanchiert
sich die armee dafür bei ihr in dem sie
sie gewaltsam gestürzt und verhaftet hat
die frage ist also warum hatte es das
militär überhaupt nötig diesen putsch zu
inszenieren ist dies das ende der kurzen
jungen demokratie warum sollten wir uns
überhaupt und mehr markt kümmern
heute werden wir diese fragen
beantworten aber lasst uns zuerst einen
blick in die geschichte werfen
[Musik]
der längste bürgerkrieg der geschichte
normalerweise denken wir wenn wir über
sie sprechen an schwellenländer wie
vietnam china länder die vor 50 jahren
noch sehr arm waren heute aber auf
hochtouren wachsen nun mehr an macht ist
genau das gegenteil davon
bis mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
war myanmar oder damals noch burma die
reichste britische kolonie in der region
sie hatten alles minen mit rubinen jade
öl gas aber mit der unabhängigkeit vom
empire ging es mit dem land nur noch
berg es gibt mehr als 135 ethnische
gruppen in einem jahr
es ist also nicht schwer sich
vorzustellen wie schwierig es war sie
alle unter einem staats dach
unterzubringen ist die kolonie ihre
unabhängigkeit proklamierte rebellierten
viele der kleinen ethnischen gruppen
mehrmals gegen die neue regierung und
gründeten nicht eine sondern ganze 15
guerilla gruppen die untereinander
praktisch einen bürgerkrieg auslösten
und zwar nicht irgendeinen bürgerkrieg
wir haben es hier mit den längsten
bürgerkrieg der weltgeschichte zu tun
denn er begann 1948 und dauert bis zum
heutigen tag an
werfen wir einen blick auf folgen
bekannte
diese karte zeigt die gebiete die heute
von den verschiedenen gruppen in der
anlage kontrolliert werden gebiete denen
sich weder touristen noch die burmesen
selbst nähe sollten entfielen davon gibt
es im moment keine aktiven konflikte
aber trotzdem ist es dort sehr
gefährlich so diesmal schoss der areas
diese karte zeigt region mehrmals die
von ethnischen minderheiten kontrolliert
werden die mehr autonomie und allgemein
einen föderalen staat fordern diese
minderheiten sind an den landesgrenzen
angesiedelt welche sich der direkten
kontrolle der regierung unter dem motto
entziehen
die meisten dieser region befinden sich
in einer art kalten status quo ohne
bewaffnete konflikte die meisten von
ihnen werden jedoch autonom verwaltet
mit ihren eigenen sicherheitskräften
steuern und so weiter security forces
dachse san mateo etwas kontext zu geben
in diesen gebieten wird fast das gesamte
op und methamphetamin das in der welt
konsumiert wird produziert mit anderen
worten dies ist der standort fast aller
großen asiatischen drohende hersteller
und händler
[Musik]
und was ist mit dem teil der sich nicht
im krieg befindet sind teil des landes
in dem die rechtmäßige regierung noch
die kontrolle hat nun die wahrheit ist
dass die dinge dort auch nicht viel
besser aussehen
zuerst hat er mir einmal eine zivile
regierung aber 1962 inszenierte general
ne win einen staatsstreich und eine
lange militärdiktatur begann im
gegensatz zu thailand das ebenfalls seit
jahren eine militärdiktatur hat
zeichnete sich das militär in myanmar
durch zwei dinge aus erstens absolute
isolation jahrzehnte lang war myanmar
für ausländische investitionen fest
verschlossen
wir haben thailand automobil oder westen
fabriken mit offenen armen empfingen das
militär milliarden mark seine macht am
besten garantiert wenn das land von der
welt abgeschnitten ist und in der tat
näherten sich weder die vereinigte
staaten noch die sowjetunion diesem land
an das erklärt zum beispiel warum viele
staaten nicht einmal seinen neuen namen
anerkennen und falls ihr nach diesem
land auch packen sucht damit ihr
feststellen dass es immer um die zwei
namen auftaucht wo wir und das ist der
name den ich hatte als eine britische
kolonie war und mir dann mal was ist der
name den das militär gegeben hat aber
welche ideologie hatten diese militärs
waren sie links oder rechts extremisten
waren sie religiös oder atheistisch nun
nichts von alldem wir können sagen dass
myanmar seit jahrzehnten eine
militärisch astrologische diktatur ist
liegt völlig ballaballa und ist es auch
ein beispiel general ne win hatte eine
lieblingszahl die 9
und zwar deshalb weil sie ihm von einem
astrologen empfohlen worden war
infolgedessen verbot er von einem tag
auf den anderen alle banknoten mit einem
wert nicht durch nun teilbar war
[Musik]
das heißt er ließ nur noch die 45 und 90
kg banknoten im umlauf aber wartet zu
allem überfluss war das schon das dritte
mal dass er das geld seiner landsleute
in wertloses buntes papier verwandelt
hatte und das ist nur eine von vielen
anekdoten der esoteriker generäle die
hauptstadt von myanmar heißt nico eine
stadt die es vor 20 jahren noch gar
nicht gab der bau begann 2002 und 2005
war sie bereits die hauptstadt eine
stadt mit massiven mehrspurigen straßen
mutter schönen goldenen pagoden und
riesigen geister vierteln und warum
wurde diese stadt ausgerechnet an jener
stelle aus dem boden gestampft nun auch
dies war eine entscheidung die von den
sternen diktiert wurde und wie euch
sicherlich vorstellen könnt ist die
wirtschaft miramax unter solchen
bedingungen und ich weiß nicht ob man so
etwas wirklich als regierungsprogramm
bezeichnen kann
erst vor ein paar jahren in schwung
gekommen die haben thailand und china
begonnen haben eine mittelschicht zu
entwickeln ist mir dann mag immer noch
ein sehr armes land und das obwohl es
über natürliche ressourcen verfügt wer
euch vorstellen könnt gefiel den besen
diese diktatur überhaupt nicht und das
bringt uns zu der großen nationalhelden
auf sushi tochter eines der väter der
burmesischen unabhängigkeit und nach dem
staatsstreich von 962 im exil doch 1988
kehrte sie in das land zurück
unterstützt von tausenden von bürgern
wir wollten dass sie in die politik geht
und ihr fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
ob die militär- und da wirklich bereit
war ihre macht zu teilen nun
offensichtlich nicht tatsächlich gab es
1990 zu einem ersten versuch freie
wahlen zu organisieren dass mir ernst
dabei nur zehn von 492 sitzen also
annullierte es die ergebnisse und kehrte
zur ewigen astro diktatur zurück und
währenddessen stand aus als sie unter
hausarrest und so ging es 15 jahre lang
weiter während sie unter arrest stand
erhielt sie einen rings robert reisz ein
sacharow menschenrechtspreis und youtube
schrieb sogar einen song für sie im
gegensatz zu venezuela oder nordkorea
hatte mir nach diktatur jedoch keinerlei
internationalen verbündeten der sie
unterstützen würde
und das erklärt warum selbst als myanmar
sich dem internationalen markt öffnen
wollte der internationale markt folgende
sagte und deswegen sah sich das militär
ab 2003 dann doch gezwungen die
sogenannte roadmap to democracy das
leben zu rufen
den fahrplan in die demokratie denn
einen staatsstreich zu organisieren
braucht nicht viel zeit aber das land zu
demokratisieren ist sehr mühsam vor
allem wenn man seine macht eigentlich
gar nicht verlieren will
und wenn man sich über viele jahrzehnte
daran gewöhnt hat politische gegner des
gefängnis zu werfen wenn sie einmal auf
die nerven gehen ist ist nicht einfach
die sind braucht einfach wieder
abzuschwören so was dauert mindestens
mal zehn jahren und das bringt uns ins
jahr 2015
was geschah also in ihnen ja die große
enttäuschung
2015 könnte die economist myanmar zum
land des jahres und das war kein wunder
nach zwölf jahren vorbereitungen auf die
demokratie geht im januar seine ersten
allgemeinen wahlen ab und die partei von
aus dem ski die sogenannte national
league for democracy gewann 86 prozent
der sitze
außerdem konnte jedoch nicht präsident
werden
denn der weg zu demokratie ist ein
langer weg und das militär sorgte dafür
dass die demokratische verfassung
myanmars auf dem weg zur
demokratisierung nicht zu schnell
vorankamen also fügten sie einen
paragrafen 1
da ist jede der familienmitglieder im
ausland verbietet das amt des
präsidenten zu begleiten denn
ausnahmslos ist zufällig mit einem
briten verheiratet
schon allein dieses beispiel ist könnt
ihr euch einen vorschlag machen und er
macht welche die armee getötete d'amato
im lande innehatte eine sache ist jedoch
sicher im januar hatte sich der welt
geöffnet in der tat seit der fahrplan
zur demokratie angekündigt wurde baten
das militär gesetze auf den weg um
ausländische investitionen zu
ermöglichen
als auch sushi an die macht kam hatte
sich das bruttoinlandsprodukt im laufe
der vergangenen zehn jahre bereits
verdoppelt firmen wie h&m inditex oder
primark errichteten bereits ihre ersten
fabriken in der region und wir sprechen
nicht nur von westlichen firmen werfen
wir einen blick auf diese zeit
[Musik]
china würde gerne einen hafen im
indischen ozean haben okay es hat
bereits einen hafen in bangladesch aber
um nach bangladesch zu gelangen muss das
erstmal durch den erzfeind indien
hindurch allerdings verfügt china über
eine direkte gerade ist das mehr an
macht was einen viel einfachen zugang
zum ozean bieten könnte und das erklärt
natürlich mache ich nun wie diese china
und marc vereinbaren die errichtung des
wichtigen seitenstraßen hafens zu
beschleunigen
wir haben in der stadt krakow wäre
chinas tiefseehafen im indischen ozean
aber auch für indien ist mehr ein markt
von interesse weil es ein logisches tor
nach südostasien darstellt mit anderen
worten es gab keinen mangel
anpassungsmöglichkeiten das problem war
die burmesische demokratie also verbot
die paradoxon sushi bei den wahlen
direkt zu kandidieren und sorgte
außerdem dafür dass sie die macht auch
anderweitig nicht fest im griff haben
konter zum beispiel über ihre datei zum
einen er liest die konnte ein gesetz das
ihr 25 prozent der sitze im parlament
schon mal automatisch zu fall ließ zum
anderen berichten sie darüber hinaus
quasi ein vetorecht durch welches es
praktisch unmöglich ist gesetze ohne
ihre unterstützung zu verabschieden
so bat höptner der wirtschaft in myanmar
operieren noch immer abseits des
gesetzlichen rahmens in einer
schattenwirtschaft fehlende
rechtssicherheit ist das größte
hindernis bei der liberalisierung der
wirtschaft welche es dem land erlauben
würde sein potenzial zu entfalten
bürokratie muss abgebaut und
vereinheitlicht werden um investitionen
und die entstehung einer mittelschicht
zu ermöglichen das potenzial ist immer
noch vorhanden
dies ist jedoch nicht das hauptproblem
ist das größte problem in diesem land
ist immer noch die menschenrechtslage im
jahr 2017 geschah in einer provinz im
westen des landes folgendes
[Musik]
40 helfer seit oktober niedergebrannt
erinnert ihr euch noch als ich von den
135 offiziell anerkannten ethnischen
minderheiten erzielt hat nun die
rohingya sind nicht einmal auf dieser
liste vertreten sie werden als
ausländische flüchtlinge betrachtet also
erkennen myanmar sich nicht als seine
eigenen bürger an verweigert ihnen den
zugang zu den grundlegendsten
staatsleistungen und liquidiert sie
jetzt gänzlich mit hilfe der armee
und in der tat ist der general der
jüngste angeführt hat derselbe general
der den völkermord begonnen hat die rede
ist von general mills und damian maria
durch den fahrplan in der demokratie zu
einem modernen welt auf dem land wurde
wo sie die ganze hass kampagne gegen die
auch hinter natürlich standesgemäß auf
facebook losgetreten dieser herr
orchestrierte eine konzertierte
facebook-kampagne die damit endete dass
ein unterteil der panamesischen
bevölkerung den völkermord an den rohen
gar unterstützte als ergebnis wurden
mehr als 25.000 menschen von der armee
getötet rund 750.000 vertrieben
[Musik]
und ihr fragt euch vielleicht was die
reaktionen der
friedensnobelpreisträgerin darauf war
was du dir tippen was hat der asiatische
nelson mandela getan jede frau welcher
die band you to eines song gewidmet hat
ja nicht mehr und nicht weniger als vor
dem internationalen gerichtshof zu
erscheinen um das militär zu verteidigen
es gibt zwei erklärungen für all das die
erste ist dass sich auch sanssouci die
direkte konfrontation mit der armee
einfach nicht leisten kann
die zweite ist das so schrecklich es uns
auch erscheinen mag sie sich der
öffentlichen meinung in myanmar beugt
welche den völkermord an den rändern
nunmal befürwortet hat in der tat könnte
man sagen dass außer dem sie die
internationale unterstützung opfert hat
um im gegenzug den applaus ihres ganzen
landes zu gewinnen und das erklärt
schlagzeilen wie die folgende die wahl
in myanmar bringt einen weiteren
entscheidenden sieg für aussagen zum ski
das war im jahr 2020 und die partei von
sony gewannen mehr sitze als je zuvor
tja in myanmar ist diese frau noch
beliebter als bono in irland warum also
hat die armee gegen sie geputzt genau
das werden wir uns ansehen passt also
gut aus
der aerobic putsch kommen wir zurück zur
oberbefehlshaber der burmesischen armee
müssten hier
er steht kurz davor 65 jahre alt zu
werden also jenes alter in dem ihren
magischen militärs gezogen sind in den
ruhestand zu gehen
tja und was ist wohl der einzige level
dieser herr in seinem tropico im
reallife noch anlocken kann
genau der oberste boss level er will
entgegen da werden also präsident von
mir an lag aber nicht nur das das
militär hat angst dass aus sushi die
verfassung ändern könnte um es von der
macht abzuschneiden wenn man bedenkt wie
beliebt sie ist wird diese möglichkeit
immer wahrscheinlicher also gab es nur
eine andere möglichkeit ein
staatsstreich
die armee hat gesagt dass die wahlen
gefälscht waren obwohl sie keine beweise
dafür vorgelegt haben und mit hilfe
dieser rechtfertigung sind sie dann mit
gewalt an die macht zurückgekehrt und
soweit keine große überraschung also es
ist nicht das erste mal ist die armee
demokratie versprochen und dann einen
staatsstreich durchgeführt hat als sie
sah dass sie die macht dann doch
irgendwie verlieren könnte
das neue an diesem fall ist die reaktion
der bürger
[Musik]
myanmar coach demonstranten trotzten der
warnung des militärs in einem
massenstreik libanesen sind in der regel
friedvolle menschen und sie respektieren
die obrigkeit deswegen haben sie es in
der vergangenheit auch über längere
zeiträume ausgehalten unter autoritären
regimes zu leben und den amateur weiß
dass diesmal ist sie auch etwas anders
die neue generation die mit dem internet
aufgewachsen ist und die ersten schritte
des landes in richtung globalisierung
miterlebt hat weiß jedoch wie sicherheit
anfühlt und welchen wohlstand
wirtschaftswachstum bringen kann
sie sind nicht bereit zum alten system
zurückzukehren im augenblick ist die
gesamte wirtschaft myanmar ist
paralysiert viele geschäfte sind
geschlossen und den menschen rekrutieren
unternehmen die mit dem militär in
verbindung gebracht werden und sie
verweigert die zahlung der
mehrwertsteuer auf produkte tatsächlich
wird das beliebteste des landes wollen
der armee hergestellt die meisten
geschäfte haben es aus ihren regalen
entfernt und wurde sogar die zahlungen
von einkommensteuer verweigern
währenddessen hat das militär die
internetverbindungen gekappt um die
proteste zu stoppen zu denen sich
tausende und abertausende von
demonstranten verschiedenster ethnien
und sozialer schichten in den straßen
zusammen finden sie eigentlich die
ablehnung des vorgehens der armee und
die unterstützung der bei den letzten
wahlen november gewählten regierung sie
demonstrieren bereits seit mehreren
wochen
und es sieht nicht danach aus als würden
sie aufgeben diese reaktion war
vollkommen unerwartet und hat die
generäle kalt erwischt
[Musik]
wenn in der vergangenheit akzeptierte
die burmesische bevölkerung die eiserne
faust der tam ag
aber zum zeitpunkt des drehs videos ist
fast die gesamte wirtschaft dann machst
du stillstand gekommen tatsächlich
handelt es sich nicht nur um einen
arbeitsstreik soll auch um einen
steuerstreit viele burmesen haben
bereits gesagt dass sie keine steuern
mehr zahlen werden bis der putsch vorbei
ist die kunst greift zu den alten
mitteln der isolation durch abschaltung
des internet und zu brutaler gewalt
während wir dieses video drehen ist
bereits von mehr als 500 toten im ganzen
land die rede
die internationale gemeinschaft ist und
die militärs unter druck unter anderem
indonesien und die philippinen die
vereinigten staaten und die eu haben
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen dieter
mahndorf erhält die große frage bei
diesen sanktionen ist jedoch was ist mit
china wenn die usa und europa alle ihre
handelsbeziehungen mit mir einmal
wiederkommen würden würde es zu 100
prozent in chinas hände fall eine lose
lose situation also deswegen ist die
frage an euch was denkt ihr wie ist es
möglich den staatsstreich im jahr einmal
zu stoppen was könnte man tun um die
demokratie in diesem land macht zu
retten wird chinas expansionspolitik
hier einen weiteren erfolg gegen den
besten erringen können
wie immer sind sie auf eure kommentare
schon sehr gespannt bevor ich zum
schluss komme möchte ich mich aber noch
bei pablo bedanken der uns bei der
recherche für dieses video sehr geholfen
hat obwohl die kommunikation aufgrund
von internet ausfälle natürlich sehr
schwierig war
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat was ja geht uns wieder ein
leichtes mit euren freunden und vergisst
auch nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren
als gut und bis bald
[Musik]